[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka
guten Abend der Winter hat noch nicht
begonnen aber in vielen Krankenhäusern
herrscht bereits eingeschränkter Betrieb
auf den Intensivstationen Operationen
werden verschoben Kliniken melden sich
von den Rettungsleitstellen ab mit der
Folge das Patienten im Rettungswagen
durch die Gegend gefahren werden bis
sich endlich an Krankenhaus findet das
bereit ist sie aufzunehmen was nicht
heißt dass man dann auch gleich
behandelt wird wer nicht den akuter
Lebensgefahr ist muss damit rechnen
viele Stunden zu warten bis jemand Zeit
hat sich zu kümmern aber nicht nur
Kliniken sind überlastet und
unterbesetzt darüber klagen auch
Hausärzte darüber spreche ich gleich
noch mit dem Bundesgesundheitsminister
zunächst aber Sibylle Basler mit
aktuellen Eindrücken aus unserem
Gesundheitswesen
Nicola fritz ist Hausärztin seit Wochen
ist sie am Anschlag MitarbeiterInnen
haben gekündigt neues Fachpersonal
fehlanzeige
ich verwalte den Mangel wir hatten
früher fünf Fachkräfte wir haben jetzt
noch eine Fachkraft und der Rest sind
tatsächlich Lehrlinge Aushilfen
Medizinstudenten das heißt mehr Arbeiter
weniger Schultern die Folge kaum Zeit
für Patienten kürzere Sprechstunden
längere Wartezeiten schwere
Erreichbarkeit wir haben neulichst mal
gemessen und haben festgestellt dass wir
in einer Stunde 90 Telefonanrufe haben
das kann natürlich auch keiner mehr
bearbeiten
bundesweit ist jede fünfte Arztpraxis
unterbesetzt häufige Gründe für den
Personalmangel geringe Wertschätzung und
extreme Arbeitsbedingungen seit Corona
Notruf auch aus den Notaufnahmen bereits
vor Wochen schlugen Medizinerinnen wie
Oberärztin roßbach-weg wegen permanenter
Überlastung Alarm hier sind mehr als
alle Plätze belegt durch den
Personalmangel in der Pflege sind wir
schon lange mit halber Besetzung hier
immer öfter können Sie niemanden mehr
aufnehmen weil sie voll sind und melden
sich von den Rettungsleitstellen ab zu
viele Patienten zu wenig Fachkräfte auch
auf den normalstationen das führt dazu
dass die Patienten die hierher kommen
und die stationär aufgenommen werden
müssen dass wir kein Bett für sie haben
und die Patienten entsprechend in der
Notaufnahme liegen was wiederum lange
Wartezeiten für die Notfallpatienten
verzögerte Diagnostik und
Behandlungsabläufe bedeutet ein
Teufelskreis und nicht nur das es gibt
sicherheitsgefälle in denen solche
überlastungssituationen indem dann halt
alle unter Stress sind Dinge übersehen
werden und dann ist die
Patientensicherheit auch gefährdet der
Stress Tierkliniken setzt sich bei den
Rettungsdiensten fort sind die
Notaufnahmen dicht ist es Ihr Problem
die schwerkranken unterzubringen denn im
Gegensatz zu den meisten Kliniken können
sie sich nicht abmelden wir sind einfach
ein schwaches Bindeglied dazwischen was
alles ausbaden muss es ist eine
Krankenhaus hat sich abgemeldet und so
langsam sind alle vom Netz gegangen und
wird zum Transportzeiten von einer
Stunde nichts Unnormales und wir kriegen
die Patienten ins Auto wir kriegen sie
dann aber nicht mehr im Krankenhaus los
zurück zu Nicola Fritz bei allem Bemühen
für ihre Patienten hat die 52-Jährige
häufig ein schlechtes Gewissen nicht
alles gegeben zu haben es ist nur die
Hälfte gemacht wir verschieben es auf
den nächsten Tag in der Hoffnung dass es
vielleicht auch eine Nothilfe gibt weil
ich es vielleicht wieder nicht geschafft
habe oder auch manchmal nur einfach
cross my fingers wird schon gut gehen
Alarmstufe Rot in Kliniken und
Arztpraxen nur ein raschereingriff kann
jetzt noch retten
der Bundesgesundheitsminister hat jetzt
zunächst mal eine Art Not-OP
durchgeführt allerdings eher mit
Pflaster als mit Skalpellen mit einem
Gesetz dass das Milliardenloch bei den
gesetzlichen Krankenkassen stopfen soll
damit im kommenden Jahr Einnahmen und
Ausgaben nicht noch weiter
auseinanderklaffen der Bundestag hat das
am Donnerstag auch so verabschiedet nur
sind sich im Gesundheitswesen alle einig
dass damit die grundsätzlichen Probleme
nicht gelöst werden hier etwas sparen da
etwas Beiträge erhöhen die Fehler im
System aber bleiben worin diese Fehler
liegen darüber hat Britta Spiekermann
mit jenen gesprochen die darin arbeiten
ausgezehrt erschöpft im dritten Jahr der
Pandemie das Personal in Kliniken nicht
nur müde sondern wütend wir sind am
Limit ist auch die Warnung vieler
Ärztinnen und Ärzte der Berliner Charité
ich liebe meinen Beruf aber die Liebe
ist erschöpft ich will kein Held mehr
sein ich habe die Schnauze voll und wenn
sich nichts ändert werde ich unsere
Beziehung beenden meine Liebe ist leider
verstorben alleine aber gut dokumentiert
und garantiert abgerechnet mehr Geld
bessere Arbeitsbedingungen und vor allem
Schluss mit einem bundesweiten
kliniksystem das Personal als
Kostenfaktor Patienten als Umsatzbringer
sieht Karl Lauterbach selbst hat das
sogenannte Fallpauschalensystem vor 20
Jahren mit der damaligen Ministerin Ulla
Schmidt eingeführt nun die abkehren die
fallböcher haben die Kliniken ja
komplett durch ökonomisiert man bekommt
einen Betrag pro Fall und wenn ich den
billig erbringe mache ich gewinnen habe
ich hohe Kosten mache ich Verlust mit
allen Fehlentwicklungen zu viele auch
unnötige Operationen und Personalabbau
Reform ja sagt die Vertretung der
Kliniken aber mit uns im Moment haben
wir nicht den Eindruck dass der Minister
auf die Akteure im Gesundheitswesen
wirklich aktiv zu geht uns einbezieht
mit uns diskutiert wir werden vielfach
außen vorgehalten 20 Jahre keine
substanzielle Reform Lösungsansätze gibt
es wir haben grundsätzlich ja im
Gesundheitswesen insbesondere den
Krankenhäusern einen Finanzierungssystem
was sehr stark darauf beruht dass nur
dann auch Geld fließt wenn eine
Behandlung erbracht worden ist das
unterscheidet uns ja ganz grundlegend
zum Beispiel von der Feuerwehr wo auch
eine Vorhaltung also einfach das Dasein
eines Feuerwehrwagens und des Personals
bezahlt wird also
Daseinsvorsorge ohne Umsatzdruck und vor
allem weniger stationäre Behandlungen
wir müssen es schaffen dass die
leichteren Fälle aus der stationären
Versorgung herauskommen dass wir
pauschalen neu fassen für leichtere Ops
beispielsweise die dann entweder gleich
ganz ambulant in der vertragsärztlichen
Versorgung gemacht werden können oder
eben in ambulanten OP-Zentren
weiterer Schritt scheint unvermeidbar
wir haben natürlich in bestimmten
Ballungszentren wie zum Beispiel im
Ruhrgebiet haben wir natürlich ein
deutliche Überversorgung da werden wir
Umschließungen nicht um hinkommen aber
gerade im ländlichen Bereich muss man
eben genau prüfen vor Ort was an dieser
Stelle das Beste ist
1.900 Kliniken gibt es in Deutschland
bei der Charité wird das Licht nicht
ausgehen andere Kliniken aber werden
einen Reformprozess wohl kaum überleben
und der Bundesgesundheitsminister ist
uns zugeschaltet guten Abend Herr
Lauterbach guten Abend Frau schlanker
mit gern nochmal auf dieses Szenario
eingehen dass man da erstens eventuell
ziemlich lang auf dem Rettungswagen
warten muss und dann fährt man dadurch
die Gegend vielleicht eine Stunde sogar
oder zwei bis ich im Krankenhaus findet
dass einen aufnimmt ich meine das kann
doch eigentlich in einem so hoch
versorgten Gesundheitssystem in einem
letztendlich so reichen Land wie
Deutschland doch eigentlich nicht wahr
sein oder ja das ist auch Gott sei Dank
die Ausnahme muss man sagen da darf man
die Menschen auch nicht beunruhigen aber
es ist so dass wir derzeit wieder hohe
fahrzahlen durch die corona-pandemie
haben und die Intensivstationen sind
überlastet sind schon lange überlastet
als auch Personal abgebaut worden weil
die Menschheit nicht mehr durchgehalten
haben daher bin ich auch immer wieder
überrascht wenn ich höre die Maßnahmen
sollen jetzt eingestellt werden das
würde natürlich dazu führen dass wir
noch mehr Fälle haben wir haben auch im
Moment eine relativ hohe sterbezahl das
ist also nicht unbedingt das was wir
jetzt machen sollten irgendwann kommt
der Punkt wo die Länder auch überlegen
müssen ob sie die instr benutzen die wir
jetzt zur Verfügung gestellt haben dass
vielleicht mit der maskenpflicht
gearbeitet wird aber das ist von den
Ländern zu entscheiden die Instrumente
sind alle vorbereitet jetzt machen sie
gerade ein bisschen das was ihnen in
verschiedenen Artikeln in letzter Zeit
vorgeworfen wurde nämlich das immer dann
wenn zum grundsätzliche Probleme im
Gesundheitswesen geht sie dann über
Corona sprechen das ist natürlich
wichtig die corona-pandemie verschärft
das ja auch alles aber die
grundsätzliche Problematik dass sich
Kliniken von den Leipziger von den
rettungsleitsystemen abmelden dass sie
nicht genügend Personal haben es war
Betten aber keine Leute die sich um die
kümmern die in den Betten liegen das ist
ja schon vor Corona so gewesen und wird
jetzt halt noch mal verschärft das ist
richtig also ich wollte dieses Beispiel
nur bringen weil jetzt kurzfristig
natürlich die also Intensivstation
überlastet sein könnten aber man muss
sagen 20 Jahre hat sich ja nichts jetzt
geändert und wir haben auch in den
letzten Jahren viel über diese Probleme
gesprochen niemand hat etwas getan wir
haben ja jetzt drei Gesetze die in
dieser Woche schon zum Krankenhaus
besprochen werden mit den Ländern
nämlich die also Herausnahme der
Kinderkrankenhäuser aus dem
fahrpauschalen die Sicherstellung
bessere Versorgung der Geburtshilfe und
auch dass die Leistungen erbracht werden
können ohne im Krankenhaus ohne dass die
Patienten über Nacht bleiben müssen das
jetzt natürlich Pflegekräfte frei drei
Reformen die wir mit den Ländern in
dieser Woche schon besprechen und eine
große Reform der fahrpauschale
Überwindung der farbauschale habe ich ja
angekündigt daran arbeiten wir seit
Monaten über Jahre hinweg ist da gar
nichts passiert über uns auch nichts
nachdem sich die betroffenen Verbände
getroffen haben jetzt haben wir das
vorbereitet und sind in schneller vor
also Umsetzung haben also Fallpauschalen
heißt ja man bekommt für eine Behandlung
einer bestimmten Krankheit einen festen
Betrag von den Krankenkassen heißt das
dass Sie sich vorstellen können dann so
eine Richtung zu gehen wie wir das eben
im Beitrag gehört haben es war der
schöne Begriff daeinsvorsorge ohne
Umsatzdruck weil die Feuerwehr wird ja
auch nicht nur bezahlt wenn es brennt
sondern halt einfach dafür dass sie da
ist
nein das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
sondern daran arbeiten wir wir arbeiten
jetzt an einem System was die
fahrpauschale überwinden soll es wurde
ja ein Beitrag schon darauf hingewiesen
dass ich vor 20 Jahren an der Einführung
mit beteiligt gewesen bin das hat sich
jetzt so stark versetzt ständig dass der
ökonomische Druck zu stark ist das heißt
wir arbeiten jetzt mit dem Expertenrat
in der dort haben an einem System wo
Vorhaltekosten bezahlt werden wo das
Krankenhaus Geld bekommt einfach um
diese Leistung anbieten zu können oder
ökonomische Druck stark herausgenommen
wird und wo auch übrigens die Frage
beantwortet wird brauchen wir dieses
Krankenhaus wie wichtig ist das
Krankenhaus in dieser Region wo die
Verteilung der Krankenhäuser auch eine
Rolle spielt diese Reform wird mit einer
Regierungskommission seit Monaten
vorbereitet also sie könnten sie auch
vorstellen kleinere Kliniken zu
schließen also letztendlich müssen die
Länder das entscheiden aber das
vorzuschlagen
der Bund schlägt so etwas nicht vor was
wir derzeit haben die Kleinen Kliniken
die werden zum Teil gebraucht aber sie
werden nicht gebraucht damit sie sei ihr
mal Gewinne machen müssen sondern die
müssen dort wo sie benötigt werden die
kleinen Kliniken werden oft benötigt
müssen die einfach Geld bekommen dafür
dass sie einfach da sind und müssen auch
mehr ambulante Leistungen bringen wir
haben nicht die Pflegekräfte um alles
stationär zu machen da er übrigens auch
diese Reform die wir in dieser Woche
schon besprechen wollen dass man im
Krankenhaus behandelt werden kann aber
nicht übernachten muss damit werden
viele Schichtdienste überflüssig aber
das betrifft natürlich nur Patienten
denen so geht dass man sie auch
tatsächlich nach Hause schicken kann
eigentlich viele also das sehen wir ja
es wird ja in Deutschland viel mehr
stationär gemacht als in anderen Ländern
wir haben 50% mehr stationäre Aufnahmen
als die Länder um uns herum ohne dass
das die Qualität Verbesserung
das ist das komische also bezogen auf
die Einwohnerzahl haben wir gar nicht
mal so viel weniger Pflegekräfte als
andere Länder aber wir haben viel zu
wenig Pflegekräfte bezogen auf die
Anzahl der Patienten sind die Deutschen
denn so viel stärker als andere nein sie
sind nicht kränker aber wir machen alles
stationär wir machen sehr viel stationär
was eigentlich ambulant gemacht werden
könnte oder ohne Übernachtung der
Patienten und diese Struktur ist eine
uralte Struktur die wollen wir jetzt
überwinden das was im Beitrag von ihnen
richtigerweise also gezeigt wurde ich
habe diese Reform jetzt nicht
vorbereitet indem ich mit jeder
Krankenkasse oder mit jedem Lobbyisten
gesprochen habe war dann kommen wir
keinen Millimeter weiter wir haben das
mit Experten vorbereitet wir haben eine
Regierungskommission Krankenhaus die
Vorschläge sind weitgedient und wann
kommen die also wann wird das konkret
man muss das Ding dann auch auf die
Schiene bringen kinderkunde Geburtshilfe
und eben auch diese sage ihr mal
übernachtungsfeier Behandlung das wird
in dieser Woche mit den Ländern und den
Fraktionen besprochen und diese große
Reform dass man die fahrpauschalen
überwindet das wird in den nächsten zwei
Monaten vorgestellt ist aber auch schon
weit vorbereitet die Kommission die das
vorbereitet der hat sich mehr als 40 Mal
in dieser Sprache schon getroffen ich
bin selbst Mitglied dieser Kommission
und kann Ihnen daher sagen darüber wird
seit Monaten geredet aber keine
Kommission und auch nicht noch so viel
Geld finden die Pflegekräfte und auch
das Personal in Hausarztpraxen zum
Beispiel dass es braucht also ich glaube
wir haben eine Zahl gesehen 50.000
Stellen müssten eigentlich besetzt
werden wo sollen die herkommen ihr
Vorgänger reiste dann nach Südamerika
und versuchte Mexikaner anzuwerben das
hat nicht wirklich geklappt das stimmt
wir haben auch viel zu wenige Ärzte
langfristige im Moment geht das so
gerade noch aber wir müssen eigentlich
Zahl der Medizin Studierenden deutlich
erhöhen um bis zu 5.000 pro Jahr weil
wir bilden derzeit für die große
bedarfswelle die wir da bekommen wenn
die Babyboomer alt werden dafür haben
wir nicht genug Ärztinnen und Ärzte da
kann ich aber auch nicht alleine
entscheiden das muss mit den Ländern
entschieden werden ich habe den
Vorschlag gemacht in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen das haben die
Länder aber dann nicht mitgetragen den
Ländern war schlichtübergreifend die
Ausbildung der Medizin Studierenden zu
teuer
Lauterbach danke für das
ich danke Ihnen
und bei Heinz Wolf geht es jetzt weiter
zunächst mit dem Blick auf das
Kriegsgeschehen in der Ukraine Russland
hat nach eigenen Angaben seine Angriffe
auf Infrastruktur der Energieversorgung
und des Militärs in der Ukraine
fortgesetzt in der südukrainischen Stadt
mikulajew trafen russische Raketen ein
Wohnviertel dabei wurden ukrainischen
Angaben zufolge drei Menschen verletzt
zwei Wohngebäude ein Spielplatz und ein
Lagerhaus sollen beschädigt oder
zerstört worden sein
der sächsische Ministerpräsident
Kretschmer hat sich dafür ausgesprochen
nach dem Ende des Krieges neben anderen
Bezugsquellen auch wieder Gas aus
Russland zu nutzen gegenüber Bild am
Sonntag sagte er zu möglichen
Verhandlungen es gäbe keinen einzigen
Grund warum die Ukraine auch nur auf
einen Quadratmeter ihres Territoriums
verzichten sollten Kriegsschäden müssten
von Russland ausgeglichen
Kriegsverbrecher zur Verantwortung
gezogen werden
bei der Oberbürgermeisterwahl in
Tübingen ist Boris Palmer wiedergewählt
worden er setzte sich mit einer
absoluten Mehrheit von 52,4 Prozent
durch Palma war als unabhängiger
Kandidat angetreten seine Mitgliedschaft
bei den Grünen Ruth bis Ende 2023 wegen
Streits um tabu-brüche und
Rassismusvorwürfe immer wieder hatte er
mit provokanten Äußerungen vor allem in
den sozialen Netzwerken auf sich
aufmerksam gemacht
im Machtkampf um das Amt des britischen
Premierministers zeichnet sich ein Duell
zwischen Ex-Finanzminister sunack und
dem ehemaligen premier Johnson ab Suna
gilt mit mehr als 120 öffentlichen
Unterstützern als Favorit Johnson steht
laut seinem Team an der notwendigen
Schwelle von 100 Unterstützern die für
eine Kandidatur notwendig sind
Nominierungen können noch bis
Montagnachmittag eingehen und spätestens
am kommenden Freitag soll fest stehen
wer künftig die Regierung anführen wird
Italien wird ab sofort von rechts
regiert die neue Regierungschefin Meloni
hat offiziell die Amtsgeschäfte
übernommen nach der Vereidigung gestern
erfolgte heute die traditionelle
Übergabe der Glocke im Regierungssitz
durch den
nun-exministerpräsidenten Draghi
er verließ den Palast unter dem Applaus
seiner ehemaligen Mitarbeiter die
Regierung aus den fratelli d'Italia der
rechtspopulistischen Liga und der
konservativen Partei Berlusconis
vorzeitalia hielt im Anschluss ihren
ersten Ministerrat ab
es war eine unglaubliche Szene die sich
da gestern in Peking abspielte wir haben
hier im heute journal auch darüber
berichtet vor aller Augen vor allem auch
zahlreichen Kameras wurde der ehemalige
staatsteparteichefu Gin taub gegen
seinen Willen von Parteitags Podium
entfernt sein Nachfolger hiering Ping
der direkt neben ihm saß sah ungerührt
zu manche Beobachter fühlten sich an
sterilistische Säuberungen erinnert
Politbüro Mitglieder die öffentlich
gedemütigt und entfernt werden
heute seine neue Führungsriege
präsentierte war das dann eine
Demonstration uneingeschränkter macht
Miriam Steimer berichtet aus Peking
sieben winkende Männer
angeführt von Parteichef hier den pink
dieses Schauspiel wiederholt sich heute
zum dritten Mal es ist hieß dritte
Amtszeit um die möglich zu machen hat er
die Regeln geändert bisher war nach zwei
Amtszeiten Schluss
damit will er sich seinen Platz in den
Geschichtsbüchern sichern als
mächtigster Parteiführer seit
Staatsgründer mau zu dumm
versuchen deutsche
die Reise die vor uns liegt ist lang und
beschwerlich aber entschlossenen
Schrittes werden wir unser Ziel
erreichen wir werden uns nicht von
starken binden unruhigen Gewässern oder
gefährlichen stürmen entmutigen lassen
sogleich wie die Bilder vom
Parteikongress ist das Bild von hier
nicht geblieben man ging davon aus
anfänglich dass er so eine andere forma
sein wollen würde das hat sich dann im
Jahr im Laufe der Jahre gewandelt also
er war wurde erst so ein bisschen als
der chinesische Gorbatschow beschrieben
und da jetzt später eher der chinesische
Stalin in der neuen parteiverfassung
sind hieß Führungsrolle und seine
Ideologie als Leitlinie festgeschrieben
sein Wort ist Programm wer dem
widerspricht kann belangt werden wer ist
dagegen
keiner keiner
es ist als würden sieben Pinks auf der
Bühne stehen denn der Parteichef hat
sein höchstes Führungsgremium
ausschließlich mit vertrauten besetzt
Reformer raus loyale Kader rein
zum Beispiel Lied young er wird wohl
premier obwohl er verantwortlich ist für
das Chaos im Frühjahr während der zwei
Monate Lockdown in Shanghai doch er ist
loyal und das ist das wichtigste
Kriterium um unterhie einen Posten zu
bekommen
hier ist die Partei die Partei ist hier
Machtverteilung abgeschafft das passt
nicht zu seinem Image als hidada onkel-
sie hat auf jeden Fall sehr großen
Erfolg damit gehabt als ein freundlicher
und zurückhaltender
harmloser vielleicht sogar Politiker zu
wirken er spricht sehr ruhig und hat
eine eigentlich eine ganz angenehme
Stimme und das steht natürlich im
Kontrast zu diesem harten Politiker und
diesen diesen machtspieler den man jetzt
sieht der machtspieler ist auch eine
Gefahr außerhalb seines Landes deutsche
Geheimdienste waren vor Chinas Einfluss
auch bei uns man über China spricht
heißt es immer russland ist der Sturm
China ist der Klimawandel und der kann
heiß werden unter den heute
vorgestellten Männern ist keiner der in
fünf Jahren als Nachfolger in Frage käme
der dritte Aufmarsch mit hidden Ping an
der Spitze wird wohl nicht der letzte
gewesen sein
eine ausführliche Dokumentation unserer
Korrespondentin über archiving finden
Sie in der ZDF Mediathek unter dem Titel
Chinas neuer Kaiser
jetzt geht es bei dir noch mal weiter
Heinz mit Sport der Startschuss für den
Ski Alpin Weltcup ist doch noch gefallen
der Saisonauftakt der Frauen musste
gestern abgesagt werden die Herren
konnten heute in Sölden vor perfekter
Kulisse starten schnellster Marke oder
matt aus der Schweiz der Gesamtweltcup
und Olympiasieger weiter in Topform
bester Deutscher Alexander Schmidt auf
Platz 8 und mit direkter Qualifikation
für die WM im Februar
in der Fußball-Bundesliga hatte VfL
Bochum gegen Tabellenführer Union Berlin
2:1 gewonnen ebenfalls 2:1 endete das
Spiel Hertha BSC gegen Schalke und im
Spitzenspiel der
Frauenfußball-Bundesliga hat der VfL
Wolfsburg seine Tabellenführung gegen
den FC Bayern München verteidigt
Wolfsburg gewann 2:1
Red Bull mit Begründer Dietrich
mattheschitz ist tot er starb im Alter
von 78 Jahren
Mateschitz Karriere begann als Manager
eines zahnpastaherstellers in den 80er
Jahren brachte er dann den Energy Drink
Red Bull auf den europäischen Markt der
Grundstein für seinen späteres Medien-
und Sport Imperium dann einen Großteil
seines Vermögens investierte der
Multimilliardär in den Sport etwa in die
Formel 1 und den Fußball
der Friedenspreis des Deutschen
Buchhandels geht in diesem Jahr an einen
Schriftsteller der im Krieg lebt der
Ukrainer Serie shardan ist eine der
wichtigsten Vertreter der ukrainischen
gegenwartsituation er sucht Worte wo
andere nur noch sprachlos sind
vorentsetzen nicht nur in seinem
neuesten Werk Himmel über hakiff
beschreibt er das Überleben im Krieg das
tat ja auch schon in früheren Büchern
für die Ukraine hat der Krieg ja nicht
jetzt erst begonnen sondern schon vor
acht langen Jahren nur wurde ihn damals
nicht so zugehört wie heute
von der Verleihung in der Frankfurter
Paulskirche berichtet Peter Theissen
auch in Frankfurt auf der Buchmesse kaum
eine Minute vergeht ohne dass Herr
hisjadan die Nachrichten von der Front
zu Hause verfolgt es fällt ihm schwer in
Deutschland gefeiert zu werden während
in seiner heimatbombenfallen Menschen
sterben
manche Leute in der Ukraine sagen sogar
dass das Kulturleben aufhören müsse
Kultur habe im Krieg nichts verloren wir
bräuchten jeden Mann an der Front ich
bin da anderer Meinung eine Front ist
nur so stark wie er Hinterland und die
Menschen die dort leben brauchen ein
starkes Kulturleben denn es ist die
Kultur die ihnen Werte und Überzeugungen
vermittelt
in dieser Mission ist der Autor seit
Kriegsbeginn im Einsatz mit seiner
Punkrock-Band bespielt der
U-Bahn-Stationen in denen die Menschen
Zuflucht gefunden haben macht ihnen
überlebensmut gibt ihnen Kraft zum
Durchhalten zum Widerstand
[Musik]
seit 2014 ist der Krieg sahisha-danz
ständiger Begleiter sein Heimatort wurde
von den Russen besetzt von haarkif aus
unterstützt er als Freiwilliger die
ukrainische Armee sammelt Spenden kauft
Lebensmittel Autos und Drohnen und
findet eindringlicher Worte für das
Grauen seine Einträge in sozialen Medien
sind eine Art Chronik des Krieges
geworden daraus ist auch ein Buch
entstanden Himmel über haarkif dass die
ersten fünf Kriegsmonate schildert ein
unmittelbares unverblümtes Zeugnis des
Krieges
Poesie kann dieses beklemmende Gefühl
dass die Welt in ihrer Einzelteile
zerfällt für kurze Zeit lindern
und um es mit dem diesjährigen
friedenspreisträgersicher dann zu sagen
natürlich können Bücher den Krieg nicht
beenden aber Bücher könnt ihr im Krieg
helfen du selbst zu bleiben
diesen Friedenspreis in Zeiten des
Krieges nimmt sahisha dann mit großer
Rührung entgegen aber auch mit dem
Appell an die deutschen das ukrainische
Volk weiter entschieden in seinem Kampf
zu unterstützen
wenn wir jetzt in Angesicht dieses
blutigen dramatischen und von Russland
anfassenden Kriegers über Frieden
sprechen wollen einige eines Implantate
nicht zu Kenntnis nehmen ohne
Gerechtigkeit gibt es keinen Frieden
Service hat dann schafft es seine Wut
auf die russischen Aggressoren in große
Literatur und Humanität zu verwandeln
und ist so ein würdiger Träger des
Friedenspreises
nächste Woche wird es eine große
internationale Konferenz zum
Wiederaufbau der Ukraine geben diesen
und andere Termine hat Annegret Oster
zusammengestellt für unseren
wochenausblick
[Musik]
es geht um ein fast vier Millionen
Quadratkilometern großes Gebiet in der
Antarktis das unter Schutz gestellt
werden soll darum wird die Antarktis
Kommission ab Montag im australischen
Hoba dringen seit sechs Jahren wird die
Ausweisung des Schutzgebiets beantragt
bislang ist das Projekt am Widerstand
Chinas und Russlands gescheitert das
Südpolarmeer spielt eine entscheidende
Rolle zur Einhaltung des 1,5 Grad Ziels
am Dienstag wird eine internationale
Expertenkonferenz über den Wiederaufbau
der Ukraine beraten da Deutschland den
g7-vorsitz hat wird sie in Berlin von
Bundeskanzler Scholz und
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
eröffnet werden die Grundsatzrede wird
der ukrainische Präsident selensky
halten die Konferenz kann per Livestream
verfolgt werden
nach Unstimmigkeiten im energiestreit
auf dem EU-Gipfel vergangene Woche wird
Bundeskanzler scholzer Mittwoch vom
französischen Präsidenten macron in
Paris empfangen werden Scholz hatte
macronsvorwurf Deutschland sei in der EU
isoliert entschieden zurückgewiesen
betonte man wolle gemeinsam vorankommen
Bundespräsident Frank-Walter Steinmeier
wird am Mittwoch den renommierten
Deutschen Zukunftspreis verleihen
nominiert sind Innovationen wie eine
neue Bestrahlungstechnik für
Krebspatienten neue Möglichkeiten in der
Mikroskopie und eine turboladestation
für E-Autos der Preis ist mit 250.000
Euro dotiert
und die Wetteraussichten zum Start in
die neue Woche sind so morgen regnet es
im südenteils anhaltend vereinzelt kann
auch ein Gewitter dabei sein sonst
bleibt es bei einem Mix aus Sonne und
Wolken meist trocken im Nordwesten
kommen am Nachmittag Schauer auf bei
einem lebhaften Südwestwind werden 15
bis 22 Grad erreicht die weiteren
Aussichten in den nächsten Tagen regnet
es nur noch selten und die Sonne scheint
häufig mit Höchstwerten von 15 bis 24
Grad bleibt es weiterhin viel zu warm
das war es von uns gleich geht's weiter
mit dem sonntagskrimi und um 0.25 Uhr
gibt es dann die nächste heute Express
und hier erwarten Sie morgen eine
gelinek und Gundula Gause schönen Abend
noch wiedersehen
[Musik]